movie night yes got to have you on it
too
and welcome to punch drunk sports it is
going to be a fun festive episode jason
Tebow's in here and we're still waiting
on Ari so I brought in some friends
before we get into us I want to tell you
that today's episode puncturing sport is
brought to you by Santa Cruz medicinals
yes Santa Cruz medicinals makes potent
CBD infused coconut oil and olive oil
all their products contain 1000
milligrams of CBD and our lab tested CBD
is proven to help improve sleep reduce
anxiety reduce inflammation and help
with muscle recovery pro athletes are
using it and you can to add it to your
shakes your recipes or rub it on your
skin's topically to relieve the pain use
the promo code punch 5 for $5 off your
order so i'm assuming it's santa cruz
medicals calm they didn't send it to me
but let me look it up real quick and
joining me in studio are to my good well
we got johnny's on the ones and twos
Johnny how are you hey man Johnny ain't
thing exciting with the YouTube channel
you're doing amazing thing looks like SC
medicinals it's SC okay so I'll go to SC
medicinals comm use the promo code punch
fight and you'll get five bucks off your
order get that weed homeboy I guess we'd
fix everything now right whoa what's
that
that's me what is that it's me
connecting the Johnny's computer oh okay
okay
joining us uh are two very funny comics
they both know each other and don't know
each other they met at Morty's even
though one of them's never performed at
Marty's he's from he's from the
wonderful podcast movie night and you
can see his special on Netflix - Wayne
Perkins everybody yo what up thanks for
coming on buddy for having me I
appreciate it yes and he's on a podcast
he still doesn't do you know the
official name of it the fanatics podcast
the fan hole and a sports in comedy
podcast
kit now I'm the Laugh Factory it's on
the waianae tree podcast
who else is on that channel we have
Dahmer era as a podcast Sahni and
they're trying to build it up so I think
they're gonna have some more podcasts so
it's you and Dom it's me and Dom Sean
and Dom Sean and Dom sounds like a
zombie movie I know right or some kind
of weird like fin Dom tag yeah yeah
some weird kind of like sexy ah
Bollywood cross-dressing types of
operation Philly Italian yeah I like
that um so so tell us about your podcast
it's called the movie night and I do it
with a guy named TK Kelly yeah he's
great yeah and we basically have a guest
they they we all watch a movie not
together but we meet up and then we
discuss set movie have you guys
discussed Justice League yet and how
that was a steaming pile of dog [ __ ] did
you just watch it I watched it on the
flight back here that's pretty bad I
feel so bad because she's such a great
drop interactive Zack Snyder yeah yeah I
know too much like it's too much talking
well I feel like the DC movies in
general I don't know what they just need
to figure out what they're doing you
know like yeah maybe I that we have one
dog movie that worked and now every
movie has to be yeah somebody to die for
it to be good right right
I actually thought Zack Snyder not
Watchmen out of the park like I like the
wife and he did I taught you to grow it
so it's really good 500 it's bad that
didn't do it for me 300 hits but that's
like a heavily stylized saying it's like
yeah that's it that's a one off can I
apply that to every [ __ ] movie and
he's tried to they're just like too much
talking they're just talking
everybody's talking yeah how about kick
some ass
and you're flying angry things they
weren't scary they look dumb like they
look like like angry fairy fingers right
yeah yeah
heavy CGI bad guy if I remember
correctly right it was just oh yeah that
was bad too like he'll get his ass
kicked by yeah and the whole thing they
handle Superman was completely wrong as
well like the way they brought him back
was was dumb like they put him in Lex
Luthor's thing the scene his face must
actually they had to take off because
the other film wasn't mission position
possibly wouldn't let him shave and they
offered to pay for their CG because it's
easier to add up my session to take one
away and so what was he going back and
forth from movies yes exactly yes
bananas can you also just put on a face
I think I think it was yeah reshoot yeah
movie they had a heavy reissue because
nobody was happy with the final product
so we had to bring back people Justice
League justice yeah we had a mustache
too much talking yeah looks like 25
pounds overweight he's got that Carmelo
Anthony look yeah I left the movie too
cuz his daughter kill herself
what that's probably why the movies no I
feel like [ __ ] yeah what an [ __ ] said
that's real that's how bad that looked
that CG onion I mean it looks like
something your phone like a Instagram
and they make a Superman dorkier I mean
like they just make it an awful wired
guy he's pure of heart I suppose I guess
that's it but I mean like look at look
at our Avengers I mean or just like
infinity Wars just right into the
ass-kicking right into not even one hey
yo what's good where are we here I'm
like okay cool well you know what I
think happened with DC's you had those
Christopher Nolan Batman movies which
were great so going forward I think they
wanted to match that tone as something
to be like juxtaposed against kind of
the light heartedness at the Marvel
Universe right but I don't think they're
matching the same type of like artistic
will you then no well it's gotta be epic
if you're gonna do that it's gonna be
epic
right even though I thought Dark Knight
Rises was kind of a piece of [ __ ] but
that's my personal [ __ ] is that the one
we went to don't worry well yeah he does
he gets it back yes
does ten push-ups and then he comes back
and he's like I'm ready to fight like
four movies in one Emily well I feel
like they lost ledger and then they just
had to scramble to put something
together because they already had that
everything scheduled you know I'd like
to see Quinn Tarantino do a movie W I do
that's what they say I would never pick
him foot yeah but it's weird like simon
Pegg's like but we're still writing the
script but Tarantino films yeah he
doesn't seem to think that give him this
would you do give them Ghost Rider I
think that's a great idea most writers
him go dark with it yeah
Ghost Rider is a great character I just
got Hamed up by Cage but I actually like
those movies if you're watching this is
just it's such a badass it's a great
Ghost Rider should be along the lines of
a Deadpool right I mean like cool edgy
take chances you watch the spider-man
cartoon back in the day Ghost Rider was
like the best guy and then the Nicolas
Cage just cheesed it up yeah it's kind
of funny though it's hilarious yeah ah
you know what else is funny these NBA
playoffs hello do you guys have any
dates how the gates do you guys got
anywhere you're gonna be I guess it
depends on when this will be released go
straight out homeboy Oh true that well
tonight I'm at the Laugh Factory
oh no I fall show laugh actor in
Hollywood may 24th I'm at Malibu vines
so winery in Malibu boom and then if
you're know someone who was in Shanghai
June 29th and 30th I'll be in Shanghai I
love doing Shanghai dude yeah yeah like
do you have like so much fun directive
no in terms of mechanics on the
government and you don't else you can't
come for comedy by the way you can't do
or say mom you can't do jokes about the
Japanese Oh cuz like the rape oh thank
you I do the other guy you say you can
know your aunt uh-uh cuz you know
they'll have people from the government
hanging out in the crowd you can't call
that the government can crazy I mean but
here's it's a very interesting thing
with China okay
China like you everyone's like oh it's
like communism it's and hey listen
nobody wants communism but correct me if
wrong hmm it's
it's really free out there like you walk
around you like as an expat you can do
as long as you murder rape anybody
they literally let you do whatever you
feel free it's just it's just the
differences you know the limit as
opposed to here like there's no limit
but there is a limit yeah you kind of
have to guess it right right right yeah
they just tell you this is the limit
don't do this and you're good I find
like in daily life a lot of countries
are like that especially for people who
don't get out of the United States but
once you're outside the United States
like life is so much freer in terms of
daily restrictions like so many other
place in the world you can walk down the
street and drink a beer yeah or you can
smoke weed and eat chicken nachos and
the same established maker hey you know
what I mean and we don't really have
those get Pepsi and Coke in the same
place that's the Ed Koch of the same
place right but but so I feel like China
would be like that but yet to have like
government officials in the audience is
[ __ ] creepy and weird well I think
you know as the guy who does
conspiracies I probably do have people
in the audience we're gonna be Joshy uh
well I have Friday laugh factory Long
Beach and then Friday Saturday also haha
at the fanatics podcast at the next
podcast and I'm in Reno June 12th for
that week
at the silver legacy love it love it ah
tonight I am at the Comedy Store it is
sold out holla - boy what up which will
be I think our 20th sellout in a row
which is amazing it is then this Friday
is the first we're doing a 10-foot not
the first ever but the first one is the
Comedy Store a tinfoil hat comedy and
conspiracy night we're doing our standup
along with uh we're doing a podcast
which would be Q&A it's pretty much
there's ten tickets left so we're super
stoked about that
and then June 1st is the Live Nation and
all things comedy presents the tinfoil
hat comedy conspiracy night at cobs
comedy club in San Francisco that's Tomb
first and then June 2nd at Sacramento so
those are the dates he'll let you boy
color ha ha
all of it go check out I'll go check out
the YouTube channel it's really kicking
ass man you're doing a great job dude
great Jen a lot better than these NBA
playoffs I'll tell you that man ray like
a young Chelsea Manning you're doing a
great job how are you how are you
feeling about you-know-who right now
LeBron yeah every time
LeBron is a great player he's a great
player I have us at number seven okay
that's where I have him at and this
doesn't change anything
yeah he's doing them with LeBron does I
agree with Samantha if he wins this
series nothing wins the files he's not
winning the finals I'll be surprised if
they win a game LeBron is great but you
know we have such a concept of recency
bias embedded in us we forget so many
great players like like Larry Bird or
summer if you look at their PR averages
Larry Bird before he got hurt was doing
the same things LeBron is doing you know
and in that era at Magic Johnson to me
LeBron still hasn't passed Kobe or magic
you know here so there's still guys on
the ladder that that we just live fraud
and gone completely to Michael which i
think is unfair to Michael and to LeBron
both well here's what they say LeBron
looks like he's athleticism won't kill
Larry Bird here's career player
efficiency it's Jordan James O'Neill
David Robinson Chamberlain Chris Paul
Bob Pettit Kevin Durant that's if you
count NBA and ABA for just an NBA it's
Jordan then James yeah but if you look
at their individual people ours for
Larry Bird's is sure for the back injury
their highest season yeah this is career
are we talking about how good a guy was
at his peak though or like his career
Larry's a great specific circumstance
because he had so many few years in the
prime before he hurt his back doing his
mom's driveway and French Lick Indiana
yeah here's the thing everybody says
LeBron would destroy destroy Larry Bird
with his that athleticism oh let's not
forget the epic battles Larry Bird had
with Romney Dominique was yordan yeah
you know I mean epic battles yeah yeah
because it was not one-on-one we're not
talking about one-on-one that's not the
gates a team gay great why don't you do
it
maybe force but you grieve I mean like
LeBron oh I thought a lot of garbage I
don't I think he's great and I like
LeBron a lot too but I think the thing
that it all depends on how you're
judging it right like are you using
numbers are you using how much a person
reach their full potential because
Jordan is I'm excuse me LeBron is great
but if you put like Allen Iverson if you
gave Allen I was in LeBrons body I'm
insane LeBron or if you gave Kobe LeBron
is body then like if Kobe Kobe what
LeBrons body would be the best player
everyone black to power Michael Jordan
yeah yeah Kobe Kobe was not quite as if
Michael Jordan was very athletic
I love how everyone dismisses my own
athleticism know what I mean it's still
a sick 60s faster you know and whatever
Aaron who's playing basketball whatever
are we comparing there's no way any
LeBron is covering 1988 Michael Jordan
or 1991 Michael Jordan that's not
happening he's not gonna be able to do
pon him Jordan go right by him every
time he went as fast really my thing is
that like like magic you know people
forget magic came in as a rookie you
know in the finals played Center and he
scored 42 what is two points ladder key
that's a rookie it was saying about like
Oh Tatum there one year went way and and
you know it's like like when when magic
came in it changed that day like that
day the league is a new leaf for sure
though got cream even though he wasn't
in series and got her everybody was able
to grow the second already play with the
second greatest great players but this
whole greatest player thing in 1988 1989
Magic Johnson hands-down was considered
the greatest basketball player of all
time right I know we just laughs it's
like this it's no for anybody ever said
Larry was greater than Magic Johnson oh
sure
when Larry came in and he was up two
rings to one and all the media was
gobbing on his knob for sure they were
like Larry's basketball Jesus I don't
know maybe I don't I don't I don't do
yeah Indiana you think that might be
I do disclaimer I love Larry Bird yeah
how's it a same bar with Larry Bird I
walked in and he's taken shots of
whiskey just getting [ __ ] hammered with
this old dude who looked like he was in
ZZ Top like he had a beard going all the
way to the [ __ ] ground dude yeah just
getting [ __ ] hammered you guys right
Harry Bird stories he's a red no he's a
drunk - I had a buddy he was pretty good
basketball player and the thing about
Larry Bird is he actually hangs out at
least at that time with a lot of young
guys and they like party and stuff and
he goes over there and he's so excited
Larry Bird's house he's gonna go meet
Larry Bird and he goes I'm Larry Bird is
drunk as [ __ ] in his armchair right and
he's so excited he goes up mr. bird
tatted up big fan so nice to meet you
such an honor Larry drunkenly like
stands up staggers and he just goes suck
my [ __ ] [ __ ]
and he suspected my life I would be
that's why I love Larry Bird yeah yeah
that's who he is he had a daughter's
whole life it looks exactly like him
refused to very much 1983 lesbian gym
teacher look yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's like they don't even need to do to
Dean ain't it just like it's yours no
it's like a great story and Larry Bird
tells us suck his [ __ ] or you can read
a great moment in your life yeah I mean
it's just great I love I love watching
LeBron play I mean he's doing amazing
but people just want disgrace just like
it's in the moment so it's the greatest
thing ever and it's just he's great
well what's obsession classifying people
while they're playing why can't we just
wait a little I can't we just wait yeah
because we do a sports podcast with no
why do we have to argue like it's the
final answer you know I'm saying like
we're arguing like okay this is it but
you know the thing about LeBron to that
I like the guy and I really like them
even more in Miami I just like that move
I know maybe I like who everyone hates
but I loved it I was like go get him you
know I think who are you rooting for in
Schindler's List but my thing is I'm a
Yankee fan too so let me put that up
make sense
but um with LeBron is that so not thank
you he's worried about his legacy more
than he should be that's my issue with
him is all
for sure even in postgame interviews oh
definitely just like he's already
legislating it he's not just giving an
interview he's literally giving you the
storyline yeah and I'm like dude just
play it's great that you're that great
yeah that you can like be playing while
worrying about your legacy yeah yeah but
yeah in the bond if you just played you
know it's the opposite of being in the
moment and exactly you know the ultimate
difference for me that I think you know
a lot of young kids don't automatically
get is is the difference between LeBron
and MJ to me is LeBron is not a
homicidal winner you know like well yeah
you know what I mean LeBron is not the
level of winner Michael Jordan is he's
gonna when LeBron is said and done with
it he's gonna have every [ __ ] record
that there is and maybe even the assist
record I don't know where he is on the
rebound list he may well have every
single record okay but if you look at
the per game averages especially in the
playoffs he's just passing Jordan now
and Jordan did it in some crazy less
amount of game that's my argument two
episodes ago with these guys was
basically that LeBron is an amazing
player but we've seen him have like
mental lapses in any quits he will quit
on you and I I've seen at least two or
three times where I've seen LeBron James
quit on that quit on that series and
quit on that team's offense the first
time he left Cleveland he took off his
jersey when in Boston kicked his ass he
took off his jersey before he got off
the killer on teh West Bank his mom and
that's something about the Cavs they
just love to bang each other's girls
it's like and there's always Dino's
there's always weird a team LeBron drama
on LeBrons team there's always weird
drama on Jordan's team you may have had
drama internally he may have punch Steve
Kerr in the face but didn't affect the
team was that prime ministry the drone
was a prize
everything that team was always focused
on one thing and when LeBron there's
always a circus and there's always
distractions and there's always
something going on behind the scene
whether it's Isiah Thomas or look Ron
has a Kardashian level to him he does he
keeps his name in the news he did all
the time he's that but like that whole
thing like and he's a good guy when they
said this home spray-painting the n-word
on
house I don't think that was real and
nobody saw it there was never a picture
of it it was I did it so every [ __ ]
around what I like that's how we know
each other that's all it was racial
cries yeah I I like him here's the
problem with these playoffs is when you
become a jump shooting league and and
the screws get tight sometimes those
shots don't fall and now you can't catch
up because nobody's a post player right
you know and that's why you know let's
you talk about this before bookie
cousins could get his head screwed on
straight
he should be destroying the league he
should be and you know people say okay
the 96 Bulls wouldn't beat these
warriors or whatever I don't think these
Warriors could beat the Oh to Lakers you
know what I mean one big man one
dominant big man would completely change
the landscape of this league if there
was a Shaquille O'Neal the way he was
back then they would destroy the
Warriors every single time I think like
a guy like Shaquille right now would
change the way we play again to like I
could get healthy that's what he's
supposed to do is just annihilate they
need a couple shooters but here's a
problem there's an unwritten rule in the
NBA that nobody hits anybody because
everybody wants to make that paper and I
get that right but when you have a team
like the goal say Wars when you when we
see when you hit them it affects them
especially curry
I mean curry and like they're like all
their Bane he's calling their head me
they're hitting me then they stop
hitting him yeah if they get blown out
it says if this was the old school
league 1995 they would put that dude on
his ass every single time you went in
there just to let him know they would
test his mettle as a man you know and
I'm a big curry fan it's just the thing
is like when you make a layup and you
look at your left hand like that's the
kind of thing like like it's like
hitting a home run against a pitcher
yeah you run around those bases trot
around those bases and you're gonna get
hit in the hip with a baseball then your
next at-bat right so like you make a
layup you look at your hand like I just
did that the very next time you're going
for a layup on your floor yes and then
yeah
don't embarrass us you know I mean I
mean locate these lay up when I see
Steph Curry do a layup I'm like what is
going on here in the old comedy store
League no I can't
it's like remember remember what uh
remember what the Pistons did to Jordan
they literally beat the [ __ ] out of him
for three straight years it was like a
full metal jacket at him you know when
they put the [ __ ] coolers in the sock
and just beat the [ __ ] out of no
practically did that for three years and
he had to overcome it he didn't cry like
a [ __ ] [ __ ] and run away to go join
the Lakers or some [ __ ]
no I mean nobody wants the old-school
[ __ ] where's like Senna and the final
score is Grey 4382
37 New York next night nobody wants that
okay above we want a little weed like
dude it's a grown man's leak now I get
if during the season okay
you guys all everybody plays nice cuz
y'all try and get that paper yeah but
man once you get to that semifinal round
it should be on dude and you should be
hitting the I mean dude every time you
hit Steph Curry it throws that team off
and you say whatever you want about
Kevin Durant and he's a wonderful person
but it is Steph Curry that makes that
team special that team is a different
team with Steph Curry because he is the
greatest shooter to ever shoot I know
you love a Reggie Miller and I know you
love and there and Larry Bird they're
wonderful that's unquestionable every
it's like something we've never seen
because and it's all these guys who grow
up it's Israel either their hats were
placed they grew up in NBA gyms with
with NBA coaches telling them how to
shoot right well you know that's
actually the shittiest part of the
durant moved to me is i think we were
robbed a lot of great curry moments you
know the most fun thing in the NBA in
the last seven to ten years has been a
great steph curry game especially when
that team was coming up for the first
time and it gets not like [ __ ] the
Warriors are good holy [ __ ] the Warriors
are gonna win 73 games
there was nothing like those Steph Curry
games and now you see when Durant's on
that team he's much more deferential to
KD and spent
in terms of the office it's not the same
do its washing to ram i masu though I
mean yeah absolutely and the team that
players aren't as competitive as they
used to be they don't want to compete
with each other the same way that they
used to because they're friends off the
court they do business deals all that's
and I also think I also think the shoe
money is so big like what you're saying
about everyone wants to make the paper
the shoe money is so big for some of
these guys the game is almost incidental
the game is almost more of a commercial
yeah because they're making they're
making more money off their shoe deal
than they are off off the damn plane and
game these guys grow up his friend
seemed like it wasn't until Jordan like
the first Nike all-american I think was
like in the 1770s right when that kind
of that culture started you're talking
about like the AAU is the national yeah
yeah and so like the Nike all-american
started in the late 70s I believe and I
think Jordan wasn't michiel American but
but for the most part in the 80s like
you with the best player in New York in
Cali maybe at the McDonald's maybe like
you know now you grow up with him like
cuz they pluck you out you know like
Stephon Marbury's from my neighborhood
he gets plucked out at 11:00 like you
know what he's there he's way better
he's not gonna play with you guys in
here he's gonna play and so now he comes
up playing you know competition you all
make it to the NBA and then you're all
friends you've been friends a long time
dude
and now you're like cool you were in the
Gold Club and North Carolina's got
there's something about him that's he's
nasty dude he's got he plays with anger
and cuz he did the um he was in the
McDonald's all-american game and they
were talking about everybody but him and
you saw him he plays nasty dude he's
coming in next year that's that time
classes time Brady back no this one
coming in right now it's insane this
Zion Williams everyone's like he's gonna
be got he's gonna be a PJ he's gonna be
a mega PJ Tucker thinks like PJ like you
ever watched PJ Tucker nobody talks
about this guy like they give draymond
Green all this things for being a little
guy carrying a garden big guys PJ Tucker
smaller than draymond Green and he
covers
power forwards dude well what do you
think the Rockets need to do to get back
in this series
they could win the next one dude they
can win the next do they have to win the
next one
but think about Durant and him they
gotta beat the [ __ ] up but you think a
D'Antoni team led by James Harden is
gonna do a scene oh right team well
maybe maybe they see the ranch thing is
that with the Golden State the bad thing
about it is Durant is like remember
entourage like I like to show entourage
right but it was always that hand of God
riding on the show where it's a good
episode they get into a little trouble
and then Vinnie bails them out with some
money yeah you know or something like
that the direct is that dude are you
saying the Houston Rockets need a signed
Vincent chase I'm saying Durant is like
this get-out-of-jail-free card that the
Warriors had guess don't think it's
settled no steps team but then it was
like man the Warriors play this great
brand of basketball they share the ball
everyone at the ball is movement then
when [ __ ] gets tight it's like just give
it the kDa give it to Kady and then he
just his because his ISO level was even
beyond hardens like he's seven feet tall
he's shooting over everyone I mean it's
like everybody talks about LeBron like
you know dude KD if he puts a couple
together there's an argument about hey
do you put Jordan's brain in Katie's
body think about that he is but he
doesn't want to be a leader let's rock
you know I was just giving [ __ ] about
Allah by LeBron LeBron at least steps up
to and accepts the responsibility of a
leader Katie it's one of these guys who
wants to just play the background
let's deftly the team let Steve Kerr
lead the team and I'll just come in and
get buckets because he wants it to be
easy you know what I mean I almost
I've lost think he hated playing with
russell westbrook
yeah dude you would look at the russell
westbrook still does it he's not a guy
that can shoot the shot the end of the
game he's not that good of a shooter
well did you see I loved Westbrook I
love it's like it's an honor to watch
that guy play but his limitation is end
of the game when the the [ __ ] screws are
getting tight he can't hit the shot
because you're not a pure shooter like
these other guys he's got the guys the
emotional state doesn't affect this shot
is more like her
calibrated for them it's like a robot
shooting it's just an automatic wet clay
Thompson wet and and Westbrook is more
emotionless why you love to watch and
play but at the end of the game you need
a guy that's just this is what I do like
a Ray Ray Allen just well that's why
Reggie Miller was great because he was
kind of a combination of Reggie Miller
is great I'm glad you brought up right
can I tell you something about Reggie
Miller that well his legacy will get
lost if Reggie Miller grew up in today's
era today's game he'd be one of the best
seven players in the game without
question every year just launching
threes all the time the game didn't
exist as it did they didn't understand
the mathematics the same way or apply
the mathematics they didn't they didn't
understand that three was more than two
but they really they really did
everything they didn't take it out to
its most logical conclusions like like
the Rockets I think last year were the
first team in history to shoot more
three-pointers than two pointers well I
mean remember like Rick Pitino was such
an outlier because he would his teams
would shoot all these threes he was like
that was weird you know but now it's
who's not doing that it's every team
well I mean the Warriors in D'Antoni
even though he's on Houston have changed
basketball you look at these kids coming
in the days of being a seven footer and
you can't shoot right there's no place
for you in the NBA anymore and if you do
make to the NBA you're not gonna make
anywhere near the max money because you
can't pay somebody max money if they
can't get their own shot or at least or
shoot an open shot you know you if you
can shoot if you can play a little bit
of perimeter defense and you can hit an
open 3 pointer there's a place for you
in today's NBA I mean I mean in beat he
can shoot this this seven footer coming
out Arizona he can shoot threes DeAndre
18 and even mo Bamba has range the
problem with his he's did you see his
wingspan it's like the great history
yeah the greatest never recorded a
combine it's like seven foot ten his
wingspan seven or ten that's crazy
sounds like a Cessna you know doesn't
have killer instinct I've watched koba's
games does he go from Maria Thomas no
I'm the guy from Arizona oh yeah
who knows big man big man age weird yeah
but you know I mean I've watched people
like I knew Shaq on the murder everybody
on the murder dude Shaq would destroy
today's Li you know oh you would it
would be great but it wouldn't check I
wish there was a guy like that I want
just one center like that and bean is
that guy just can't say it games too
pretty
yeah he's more of an Olajuwon it almost
meets Nowitzki type thing going on there
I want like a [ __ ] bruiser Shaquille
I'm putting my ass in you and I'm going
in the [ __ ] basket you can't do [ __ ]
I think that guy will come but I think
things are do an outside shot so I think
not going to be the exact same thing the
last one is like what's his name's Oh
from who plays with Pau Gasol's brother
Zach Randolph yeah Zach had a nice back
today there's some there's a good
Indiana stories exact Randy Zach is
northern Indiana like he used to
apparently push all kinds of [ __ ]
weight up there right yeah yeah always
you always hear about it I don't know
what is that crazy because he had to be
a star basketball stars hold about big
baby Marvin Harrison is the biggest
[ __ ] gangster you will ever meet in
your life
you know he's quiet and [ __ ] but he's
seriously like Gustavo Fring from
Breaking Bad with he shot somebody with
a Belgian super gun that's like a rare
super gun and then he drove around to
his car wash and he dropped it in a
bucket at the car wash trying to hide it
and drove away from the shooting and
like the cops found it and [ __ ] like he
shakes a bus he shakes in the cops found
it but he got out of it because you know
he didn't he wasn't but yeah he like
shakes people down for money and [ __ ]
like he's a straight-up [ __ ] Gustavo
watch out for how about green baby Davis
is like just the NBA didn't you salt
like a super8 employee who wants to
start comedy good country I just saw him
I saw him at the federal recently he'd
go up but he's we had like two weeks
comic it was a toss comic ever like that
was good like that was tallest Gardens
pretty tall yeah I think are there any
six maybe yeah about a comedy and now
there's no but Gary Gulman is convert
taller than big baby though he's not
that tall
Oh is he well
yeah Gary Gulman is like six-six I think
but I think big babies probably like
like really six five yeah but they said
he's like a like a Berkeley thing what
it's a six four with the saggy tits you
know with but sometimes you got that
caboose it makes up for ya
for sure this is six nine but yeah I
think you're right he's probably six
seven it's crazy dude I mean it's just
suck it if Cleveland goes they're gonna
get hot or not going so I didn't think
the winning game to be honest with okay
well who'll give Golden State a better
game going neither those teams well
neither of those teams well well it
sounds like a does does LeBron want to
put another loss on his record
it's it's almost like an exhibition
series after this you know and I don't
know what the NBA does I mean cuz you
don't want restrict people well the
thing is they stopped that they stopped
Chris Paul from going to the Lakers and
that wasn't gonna be as much of a super
team as the Warriors are the reason the
Lakers didn't get that pick is because
think that didn't happen is because it
was such a rape trade it was on it was a
classic Laker rape trade where they rape
everybody and cuz back in the day it was
like we got keep the Lakers good because
they're the ones that everybody
naturally follows so they would get
these in save you look at all honey
Garriga song just like JIT raping people
dawg so this one they were getting the
best player they're getting picks and
they're getting salary relief and
they're like a guy friend cleave it's
like this is the worst trade I've ever
seen in my life
right and that's why they did in case
you just had this big like ah you know
negotiation between the players and
they're the owners and they're like no
we can't do this
I think it'll sorry I didn't mean in Rob
yeah I think that's where the answer is
though you have to incentivize the
contracts in the cap structure so that
these small market teams can pay more to
keep these guys without it necessarily
affecting their ability to sign other
players you know what I'm saying so
there has to be some kind of way that
the structure is in
devised to stay at the team that you
were drafted with because you know one
great thing that the NFL does there's
equity any team can win it doesn't
matter if you're Tampa Bay or the New
York Jets and you don't get that same
feeling in the NBA they're talking about
bringing in a Kansas City team or look
at look at my Pacers you don't have the
sense that those small market teams have
the same chance as as the Lakers well
you know those small market teams have
to do they have to our dress foreigners
I mean you look at my draft a young
truly they don't they don't grow up with
this this idea they're not in the AAU
system being told you gotta get to these
big markets right and you know Kevin
Durant didn't move because he was in a
small market he moved because he knew
nobody's gonna beat the Warriors what no
he didn't want to play with he didn't
wanna play Russell was they could have
beat the Warriors they were up 3-1 but
he talks about that they're up that's
what makes it the biggest [ __ ] move
that's what I call his [ __ ] move he
went to the team that he was up 3-1 yeah
and they you as a man should be able to
finish one game out by yourself I don't
want to hear that Westbrook shape but I
do think it was hilarious when Westbrook
had that burner account and he was
posting and he forgot to switch the ago
yeah and he was talking [ __ ] about what
like okay Dean never could have won with
Westbrook and [ __ ] so I guess you have
your answer right there
I love Westbrook I just like to know
it's just like Allen Iverson it's just
you can't have your guards shooting
every [ __ ] shot maybe I'll know
Jordan did but I'm meeting Paul George
is gone uh I just don't think the Lakers
are that close for him yeah to go get I
think it's all everyone's waiting for
LeBron to do what he's gonna do and then
I think that yeah like if the sooner he
does it than everyone else what do you
say I go to Philly I would say it's a
terrible not enough shooters you know
you should get gangster I like Paul
George on the Sixers because he's not
that giant like that he's not a son of
man the ball became Paul George
other alpha if the perfect Eno Paul
George eighties the Pacers actually but
I don't think that's gonna there's
something about the Pacers we're like
the other is kill their and they go
anywhere else they can't they just can't
we have a great we have one of the great
institutions in sports what is it with
our franchise you know really a lot
about the success of a franchise is the
people who run it and if they can do it
competently and the reason the Knicks
are terrible despite their big market
advantages is because they have
incompetent ownership we have had one of
the best organizations going back to
since since they started so Pacers are
really good at player development we
developed a [ __ ] out of our guys because
we have to we don't have any other to
ownership matter someone we've we've
we've made the most playoff your mommy
the family's crazy apps if the owners
crazy the whole establishment is bad and
you can't change the owner you can't get
rid of a GM get rid of the coach you
can't change the like look at baseball
it's like keeping this guy who owns
athletics is hurting the leak you you
have one year your your brands is never
gonna compete right you in a major so
many psychopaths especially in the San
Francisco area they would love to own
the analytics and just Gupta guide the
people on Google they could go in their
bias [ __ ] money into that it's a giant
waste man tomorrow you'll have 10 years
of you if you haven't showed it
competence to want to compete right you
know if you don't show this ability it
could be and field a team and you're not
like wants time brother where you're
buying all the players that's not funny
yeah but this isn't 1978 you don't need
to be running teams at cost to make a
profit try to win or give it up to make
your [ __ ] windfall profit and give it
up to some of us want so from you you
buy a team to compete yeah yeah you
wanna make money but you're there to win
baby if you're not there to compete
don't get in exactly it would never work
it would never work in our system but
you know like I'm sure you guys have
talked about soccer overseas has the
relegation so like you over allegations
you're in last place you know now you
got to go play in a subdivision and it's
a shame because if
started with that if they had been there
at the beginning I would have just been
accepted but now I mean we're too far
it's crazy
well you're right that's no sub League
to compare ya know what I'm saying you
don't have the same like if they had a
nodding him before and the Dayton Flyers
and you think about relegation is it
helps that the next league down to
because they get to see teams guys who
just were in the big league and the
finances I don't know if you've done
much but the finances of how that works
I mean it's devastating to a team to get
relegated they lose to you so much TV
money it's just absolutely crippling uh
and and then you can have a team in
three years go from one of the you know
almost semi-pro to being in the biggest
league in the world which is you know
yeah I'm Gor suddenly make something
because I love the shooting I love the
shooting yeah but something goes on
where these teams get called and I think
we see teams also check out too well
like you said they can't catch up so
this is the playoffs right so it's
supposed to become more competitive as
you go up right because first and eight
plays a on one point one plays and eight
yeah then then right about it if
everything goes to choc it's one and two
playing these are supposed to be the
best two teams yeah and every game is a
blowout because you get down by 12 or 14
and you're like wow well so home courts
in the NBA it's just huge I mean the
court advantage I don't really totally
understand why but it is it's just
massive in a my you know until until
there's a big that comes along and can
take advantage of these small lineups I
just think you're gonna see the trend
continue because they've done they've
done studies if your team like Houston
or Golden State just by the virtue of
putting up more threes you have a
mathematical advantage from the
beginning of the game but where that
comes into trouble like Sam is saying is
at the ends of quarters or the ends of
games not as easy to get a high quality
shot like you may not want that two
pointer at 8:54 in the second quarter
but you want that two pointer at 30
seconds right in the fourth quarter when
everyone's playing lockdown tee and you
need to be able to execute old sets
ninety-seven cents I think that's why
Boston has a little bit of an advantage
because they're so well drilled with
their play
that's that's one hell Horford is
completely under undervalued I mean he
is not appreciated at all right I think
he's a wonderful I mean he won an NCAA
two NCAA Championships you know yes and
no one from that team went on to do
anything yeah besides him ya know it was
no no no was okay but they still they
never really went that far yeah and
they'd Derrick Rose and if you want to
go see the playoffs please go to see key
guys see key for all of your ticketing
needs buying tickets can be complicated
confusing man but there's a better way
to buy go what's C key C key gives the
smart its easiest way to get tickets to
every type of live event like Nick
Youssef gonna see Taylor Swift I'll sign
when the hungry is wrong whether you're
searching for last-minute deals planning
a night out with friends or need to get
the perfect gift
see geek helps you find the best seats
at the best prices fully guaranteed
there's nothing quite like being there
in person and would seek geek you can
get closer to the action for great value
I use it all the time it's really easy
just go on the app the website they
break it down for you based on ticket
value is it a smart buy is not a smart
buy I love it and I'll Simon at the hobo
multiple ticket sales to compare prices
and find amazing deals and you get the
most bang for your buck siki Gregg's
every ticket based on value to help you
immediately identify the best seats for
your budget plus every purchase is fully
guaranteed so ya must read ba best of
all our listeners get $20 off their
first seat geek purchase just download
the C key gap enter the promo code punch
from today that promo code punch trunk
gets you $20 off your first seeking
thing purchase BAM nice what a nice
segue bro civility boxing all the time
man or do they have it at the forum
right
Friday nights right Carson at you know
what stuff up talk about we're going to
do our live event right oh yeah for UFC
to tea whatever beautif or maybe UFC
2:35 two to six Whitaker Romero no yeah
it's Whitaker it's June ninth right uh
yeah June 9 June 9 my remember we are
doing a our second punch-drunk live
viewing party for UFC 2 2 5 at the
Sycamore tavern ah there's no cost it is
free to go you can go watch the fights
for free we're getting the back section
we hang out it was so much fun last time
and then July 9th we're gonna do our
first live podcast during a fight oh so
that will let you guys know more about
that but yeah man you guys aren't UFC
guys are you more of a lot more of a
boxing guy yes but I think boxing is
wonderful right now great I think the
UFC force boxing to get to act together
and now the UFC's falling off because
they're I just feel that well box the
UFC too greedy they can't they're not
grow sport boxing has so [ __ ] itself
in the ass it's like it's like if in
1972 the NFL disbanded and there were
three or four different NFL's you know
and then it got corrupt and all corrupt
there was no title the best teams don't
play each other and then you have to pay
$60 on the weekend to watch two teams
play a regular-season game you know but
there's so much potential with boxing if
they could just get the [ __ ] thing
together and you know John McCain was
trying to do it 10 15 years ago
well these organizations all have these
little fiefdom so you know where they if
it's ridiculous been in charge
decades never give it up the progress
there's no brand of excellence there
needs to be an NBA boxing yeah NFL Obama
that guy tried to do a premier boxing
championship and just well really you
know that was like Al Haman though right
and those guys they're not gonna be it's
not gonna be promoters that rescue
boxing is not De La Hoya's got to get
together with air like these guys got it
you know but if they'll never do think
there's more money in keeping it the way
there is and every now and then you see
the fight you want to see cuz it's all
about you know like this guy needs to
fight that guy but you have to wait but
seems like before it's happening more
and they get a lot of [ __ ] yeah if they
don't because people were tired of
Mayweather nah I like MIT like he didn't
beat in uh you know he didn't fight
people that people want him to fight
right he went that when that when we
went it was he was smart about it though
he waited until Manny was a little bit
concussed beaten up and older can I
think if they were gonna fight when
Manny was on top of it when people
wanted a fight i'm i i'm pretty sure
that manny manny mota one lloyd wanted
drug testing then they wouldn't like by
the way they were a boy drug test he was
a total [ __ ] cheater but he waited he
waited seven eight more fights in you
know until Pacquiao was more degraded
then they I was in his prime and it's my
business but it's bad for the sport out
for the sport where's what's great about
UFC is those guys have to fight it makes
sense it's like a ring it does but the
problem with UFC is that the guys who
run everything are keeping all the money
and the sport that's the money isn't
growing right now look at this look how
many fights they have in a cart they
don't do that in boxing okay
so it's like and these fighters don't
get paid they don't get people
especially not televised I mean they do
have a lot of fights but they're usually
just amateurs fighting you know and like
the very beginning alright but if I was
Conor McGregor why would I ever go to
USC again unless they were gonna that's
why would i I'm getting paid a hundred
million dollars to go fight in boxing
why don't I just go fight De La Hoya or
something he should I thought he was
gonna fight Pacquiao or I know who's the
guy that oh oh because they had that
tiff where they were in the other
sparring and he was like oh like beat
him but took him his ass and Paulie
knowledge in what I hate about boxers is
when they're always like Oh MMA got you
think you're tough get into the boxing
ring no [ __ ]
you get in the MMA octagon doesn't see
yeah but it's just like don't call them
out as [ __ ] no quietly please call
him as [ __ ] don't say that that
Garcia guy did it not the one that um
who D just lose to Garcia I can't
remember
Mikey Garcia no no I like Mikey Garcia I
like oh I like I like all the boxes man
yeah it's like yeah
they've got to make more money that's
how the sport grows because you see the
UFC just signed a giant deal with ESPN
any other major sport that would be
split with the players yeah it's not
happening what do you have scores right
am I wrong no you're right I mean but
they need to figure out a way to change
that otherwise otherwise otherwise there
will be a rival to UFC that comes and
does it it's the brand once you
established a brand of excellence it's
really hard - that's because you imagine
one day MMA overtaking boxing and
pay-per-view buys people never saw that
it kind of did but it really did I mean
I am am I you know boxing gets like what
a couple milsim on these big fights
right yeah I mean that last one that
ESPN was great I think it was the
highest isn't your average UFC
pay-per-view is gonna get way more than
your average boxing event but the thing
about a boxing spectacle it still
captures the imagination of the public
in a way that that otherwise it's keep
it simple stupid think about it like
everyone relates to two dudes thrown
festa tude I miss that feeling of big
fights
I remember being young man Tyson fights
like there was no a filler city and
magic magic - it holds that both I
believe that we forgot this Joshua
versus um no Josh when Wilder fight I
mean that was great the two most
competent heavyweights I've seen since
the let's go brothers and their little
brothers had nobody to fight and we
wouldn't fight each other and fight each
other so it's great but Lennox Lewis
left that was in and with without a
heavyweight [ __ ] division without
stars in the heavyweight division boxing
is gonna have a hard time that is the
premier and the pedigree
they haven't had that since since
Holyfield and and Lennox Lennox Lewis is
the last legit guy I think you can give
other I think where was that held up
Klitschko stood up but they didn't have
anybody fight Lennox still have people
to fight well in the Klitschko just for
this first one if you remember the last
real to me the last week oh but nobody
wanted to watch it the last heavyweight
fight between two all-time greats was
Lewis and Vitali Klitschko you man it's
how he beat the [ __ ] out of him but he
got that had that cut and I had to end
the fight yeah yeah I think I was and
that that's what can i think slowest
he's like I gotta go now he's [ __ ]
the cheerleader from heroes so
everything ends well well that's
flattering me but yeah yeah you're right
I can't keep what wait this heavyweight
start at because it always trips me up
it's a 205 right I think yeah I think I
think I'm I would have to like 500 man
I'd have to fight as heavyweight that
really do it how the batter is Roy Jones
Roy Jones started from middleweight can
you imagine like he doesn't get enough
credit for that fighting all the way up
to winning a heavyweight belt
are you kidding and he is not a
heavyweight body and that's you know the
hardest thing that's do that ruins
boxers careers is coming down from way
and when Floyd Mayweather excuse me when
Roy Jones came down from wait he was
never the same boxer and Tarver gotta
but that is one of my favorite athletes
like ever if you want to watch like if
you have an afternoon you wanna smoke
weed and watch awesome like highlights
put on Roy Jones highlights I've never
seen a boxer like that well he was like
wasn't he playing in the CBA and
basketball like way again exhaling box
that night he just like beat up fools
like I saw him to hit eight left hooks
in a row like just do [ __ ] that's quite
a guy and the guy didn't get off one
punch well what it didn't land what he
was he was undefeated and they took his
belt away on some technicality like
something the coroner's say too long
came out knocked the guy out in the
first last minute of the fight either
but the thing about boxing is even
though like you don't see certain fights
the problem with MMA is that because of
the nature of the sport like you can be
better than me but I can get lucky and I
can laughter so you don't it's hard to
keep your champions unbeaten and people
need that there's like no 25 and
right right and then the very dude it's
just it is it is hot I like the heavy
way the guy won three in a row he's had
the belt longer than anybody else
because they got four ounce clubs and
they can just catch up you know they can
just catch and it's just a weird crazy
well also boxers I mean in in boxing
your promoter take like if you get a
good promoter he's gonna take care he's
not gonna bring you up too fast and get
you fighting right way over your head I
mean those guys have 15 fights before
they even face anybody who's in their
class you're right
UFC they'll throw you right in yes
especially if they don't like you but
you're a willful [ __ ] you they will
throw you in a fight where they want you
to lose cuz they they just they'll
humbly it's weird it's like when a club
owner booked some like crazy Midler to
try to blow you off the stage oh yeah
and they tell you that we just want to
see how you do it's like a kid out here
yeah at one point I felt like I was
Bruce Lee going dojo to dojo fighting
everybody's masters you know it's just
like why are we setting this up you know
you know Boston I came up in Boston even
though I'm a New Yorker and the the the
Boston headliners are like these legends
that the ones that never left like like
the guys we know like bill burr Patrice
even Dane they kind of had to leave you
know because the the headliners weren't
going anywhere and these guys just were
like killer so mainly New England they
got to cover it like guys don't have
road gigs in New England but every now
and then a guy a bigger act will go to
New England you know just set him up
they'll just put like some absolute
killer in front of them not you know he
doesn't know he's it gets into town and
you're not thinking there's some guys
been doing comedy 20 years for some
reason still in Boston it's gonna blow
me out of the water but that happens in
Boston all the time you can control the
thing in the night with me you know for
me it's like that's what I always do and
they always put me with acts that don't
fit my act and it's more like mainstream
act and they really kill so I have to
start simple with the crowd and bring
them into me deep them into I called
Gator all this guy you know I grabbed
him at the top and I bring him down
and then I drowned all right so just
it's it's interesting man yeah what is
your special coming out man that [ __ ]
was great well the editor is now working
on it again to you know if so we'll see
man it will be sooner than later I'm in
no hurry
yeah I'm re writing new [ __ ] and it's
just like you know the problem with
comedy right now is that it's more about
relatable the crowd being able to relate
to what you're talking about yeah yeah
and but there's so many people doing
comedy now and there's so many people
putting out of ours so much contest so
it's like it's so hard like how can you
be completely original right you know
and it's just like it's it's it's so
hard because you got to have this
relatability man and but if you go but
then you gotta like has anyone said that
cuz they were never said this it's it's
it's a crazy time in comedy right now
there's so many comics so many so many
comics so many people mmm more and more
people more and more economy so I want
to ask you guys something have you heard
the Josh Denny um well do you guys know
Josh tenías he's have a show on the Food
Network and he he put out a tweet to
said single single white male is the new
n-word and people went [ __ ] nuts
they got him banned from all the west
side comedy club oh he's a comedian yeah
man if you guys would like to see this
racist comedian he's on our patreon like
six months ago yeah and then they his
show was on the Food Network
but people are calling the Food Network
trying to get his show off well you know
it's just it's a silly and ridiculous
tweet that's a bad joke but he's saying
like don't say it it's holy saying that
that's whole banning and stoning and
lynching and mob mentality that's kind
of going on I don't know if it's
actually constructive to the nannies
here she is yeah there are someone come
in give me good yeah do you want Jam
yeah go do all I can I can yeah yeah I
gotta go
do I gotta go shoot something saris
about a call to you okay I'll do it you
want so you okay I'm kicking you off
you're kicking me off hey guys
it was fun fnatic spot I'm sorry wait
get the [ __ ] out your glass I'll never
I'll never be late again you're you're
two for two for late yeah but at least
I'm consistent and you live near here
I can understand feel vom was on time
yeah and he lives like [ __ ] Sundance
Utah life is so hard Sam I'll never be
late again what do you smoke and weep I
love you I was in Utah no he lives like
I was come from South Lake I think so I
think he lives in a Century City like he
lives far away and he was on time you
you live in the dumpster outside I know
what well that's cool so where are they
so they're not here yet okay she'll
still going guys everybody's tweeting
hey what's up guys Jesus Christ so
anyways he gets banned right Josh then
he gets banned he's uh he thinks his
agents gonna drop home baby and all this
[ __ ] and it's just like it's so dumb
well so dumb you want to go over there
now it's almost like he people are
acting like he set the n-word now here's
the thing Dwayne uh
it's white people going crazy absolutely
I know I know that's the case yeah yeah
cuz yeah yeah yeah joining us um she's
here on time welcome no for me yes I
said I could be here at no that's fine
we're very happy you're here Candace how
are you do you know Dwayne Perkins sure
this is the fight mommy is it officially
the fight mommy now or is it still fight
nanny it's still fighting any on Twitter
if that's what you know yeah holding on
to your single days huh Jeff dannis
everybody how are you buddy jump on
please live in the dream man how are you
how's being a dad going it's going
he's really good at it yeah like he like
jumps to things faster than I do I'm
wait let her cry a little like she'll be
fine you
my baby and then like spoils like Kurt
Kurt Fox's had a chick kid as well
I've been lurking his Instagram using
her as a prop and I saw I talked to me
it's like for the first time in my life
but uh yeah how's it going what's going
on to give us baby updates I mean look
at her right there we're trying to make
sure she's good over there so we can
talk we both want to talk and not I have
to entertain her what's with this thing
in front of me that's Johnny's that
means you're sat person okay so good as
Johnny's good how's the podcast going
danish antonio podcast is going great
O'Neill's
preparing to fight Louis J go get some
updates on this I believe he's training
hard
I know Gomez's yeah I think he'll says
he may have a wrestling coach now he's
really that's ma rules at the yard or
somewhere else I will not reveal who's
training him so let's catch you up yes
yes so we have a friend of ours his
name's jason Ellis he has a show on
Sirius radio and every year he does
something called Alice mania where he
gets all these his friends from the show
and they box each other oh wow nice it's
it's Sam spot like 10 minutes before
yeah I did dominated so all at the same
time or is it one at a time ah joining
us via the power of Skype everyone comes
in at one time
yeah nice hiking pants yeah dude you
like Bear Grylls right now they become
shorts I had a pet oh those are dope I
never go one leg down are you joy that
means you're dealing re joining us in a
studio is the fight nanny mommy
Jeff dannis and Dwayne Perkins is here
Brooklyn nine-nine no no I think he's
saying I'm just from a Brooklyn oh okay
you were gone with and then you bailed
halfway through it are you Brooklyn that
was it
are you in Brooklyn right now no like I
don't know where we're like [ __ ] the
park in the middle of the city
yeah all those people was like hey
what's fight it's Lewis J Gomez versus
one of his interns
yeah he's fighting one of the interns
getting ready and uh yeah very fast
hands yeah so as Ryan talked about this
was his feeling yeah he's talked about
it I think he's in wordly confident but
also just knows anything can happen so I
you know I don't think he doesn't want
to say too much I think Lewis has done
more of the talking so so this guy lewis
Gomez who is on legion of skanks he goes
on the internet and he starts calling
out everybody he called out Ari couple
times I the fight and then I go well the
real fight is because the his co-host
calls out everybody - I think he's
offered to fight me
he's offered the fight and you got a
black belt in Taekwondo from years ago
though that's still a black bear yeah
what do you mean like a 1 you get JC
Penney's kind of I got a participation
pick you up and put you on your
shoulders that's not a second
participation participation trophy do
you have to renew it is it like a
driver's license where you have to go in
and retake the test yes yes he has to
register his hands Wow after this fight
we'll see I don't know and this is the
winner of this the podcast fighting
champion that's a great question and so
I got real MMA MMA rules okay so they
may take out ground-and-pound because
they're like neither really save their
face and really neither of us really
know what we're doing on the ground so
let's yeah let's add you Jitsu on the
ground I love that they did it why are
they doing judge C re did this re wanted
MMA rules so that he could come up with
another reason not to fight so he's
you don't know new jiu-jitsu you just
know there is jiu-jitsu you don't know
jiu-jitsu what I do know is it I know
almost nothing and you know last enough
I mean and so you guys are gonna fight
to know what we were going to but he's
been in the talks with you you buy me
out when it is and he gets uh his uh his
booked are these powerful Jews in
Hollywood to give him [ __ ] gigs on
the road this is like the fight you know
like all the boxing matches you guys a
fight when you're like 65 yeah no one
cares
I don't know why anyone cares now I'm so
I'm so out of shape so I go the real
fight is Ryan O'Neal vs. Gomez and it
took off and now they're gonna fly you
made the fight yes the Puerto Rican
rattlesnake versus paperwork this is
been like I just got a contract 90
million dollars all things comedy exclus
you just got served
yes representing the varsity jacket re
our boss he's on the board does that
mean he's our boss who did you go
camping with yeah what chick I don't
think Kelly is a camper
oh he's not great at getting there
what does that mean I mean it's like a
[ __ ] for our hardcore that's alright
to get there yeah how long did it take
them
is he big oh no sorry that's how long it
took it's an hour and a half it took the
good thing about Robert Kelly's if you
do get attacked by a wild animal he's
gonna sacrifice himself you can outrun
[ __ ] that on purpose he's just got
he's a big man he's a lot of me I know
Bobby yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's a
glacier I know there's a stereotype
about black people not camping but in
this case that would be true yeah I
don't know me swim can I swim why don't
black Pike is wet I can swim the length
of a pool for sure but I'm not gonna
jump out of a boat
I don't know I don't think I'll make it
to shore we were actually gonna do that
today after this podcast take Twain out
to the ocean see if I'll jump out of the
boat and I guess you won't do but I just
I'll never do a try that would be the
real black horror story not get out but
somebody lost on a bow yeah that'd be
crazy like true boat like like ya see it
with a boogie board like 10 feet away
can they get to it yeah I tell people I
can't float because of my I'm just too
muscular but that's not even it sounds
like something a racist person would say
it's like Oh black people are too
muscular to float that's why they can't
swim who can say that about black yes
right I don't know if you know the rules
there's a black guy on the Olympic
swimming team now absolutely am i
thinkthere's why him Duncan was a
excellent was great he was animal
training bisexual from what the word on
the street is alleged what yeah dude
imagine that guy powering up on you if
he's a bottom you need a footstool sure
pause okay man sure yeah that's crazy he
would post it up back that ass up
literally like a bus so we were talking
about this Josh Denny situation re I
don't know if you guys heard this but I
just get on why would you get out to
take a brick to the head why wouldn't
you but you know another I think I get a
selfie with the riots but a black truck
driver saw it on TV and went and got him
and saved them they took him to the
hospital yeah but he's like [ __ ] up
for this day the truck driver Union have
the true breaker breaker 1-9 we got a
trucker in trouble well I wonder what
that code is what is it
so this comic named Josh Denny he had a
show on the Food Network
he tweeted that single white male is the
new n-word and people lost their skull
they banned him from the West Side
comedy club and even though his show was
off the Food Network they try to get it
kicked off anyway
again like the guy you showed me the
other day I don't think so
and the good news is is that he's now
doing a show with Paula Deen yeah for
the southern Network and it's a [ __ ]
huge hit what do you think he should got
banned I mean no you go you go for it
it's like dude if you play their dumb
game there's two things if you play the
game of Hollywood they get to tell you
dumb rules and you either say okay fine
I'm out or or you know mortgage what you
believe it I don't know it's like that's
the rule it's like I mean like sure say
whatever you want whatever you want
they've never said that's their game
that's a great point so like you can't
be apart if paraphrase what you're
saying Harry you can't be a part of the
system and not work within the confines
of it or you can just get out of the
system and do whatever you want it seems
to be when I've gone serious for making
a tweet that they didn't like it was
like yes sirree they've always been
firing people for tweets it's like
they're on the record it's like we will
we have the right to do it we'll do it
to you yeah it is an outrage that's it
Comedy Central by the way always seems
to stand by people and not get involved
yeah that's true they did that with our
speedrun is easy they did that with you
maybe this guy I'll get a cooking show
for a Comedy Central yeah the other part
of it though is why are people like the
Westside is bending this guy he's a
comic Jenny yeah and the Westside is a
comedy theater it's like when a comics
just gonna start going hey instead of
seeing the worst possible interpretation
of this let's just see like well that
was a friend of mine it's a comic he's
not lynching black people he's not
[ __ ] trying to not get gay people
married he's just trying to make it you
know what he's doing
yeah so who gives a [ __ ] we're trying to
see the best in it I see what can be the
best possible interpretation of this I
just think it's a slippery slope for
comedy clubs is that a racial slur you
just yeah that's why I did and I think
it's just I think it sets a bad
precedent well you know I think comedies
the last were the last sort of Mohegans
in the sense that like comedy is the one
thing that you
can't fix right people either laugh but
they don't laugh and I think for some
people like they don't like that the
game is always gonna be rigged and if
you can sort of like start rigging
comedy either by eliminating some comics
or telling people not to watch exactly
what's going on you're rigging the game
you know the other end you got people
like they're trying to use outrage to
get their drink to achieve their dreams
and it's just like yeah they're like
getting angry people and using that to
try to get into other things right
because like a lot of comics and I don't
I don't think this guy Josh was doing
this per se but I see comics I don't say
anything but you could see that they're
trying to get their voice before they
get funny and they're trying to get
their platform before they get funny and
like we came up just get funny
and then figure out what you're doing
with the funny but people are like
already have their platform and you know
doing shows at colleges or seminars and
it's like I'm like wait did I miss I
think I missed the part where you like
actually got funny you know what I mean
and so I just outraged as a part of that
yeah and I just feel that like Howie how
boring is your life when you take up
this fight as and it's all white people
it's white beta [ __ ] who are just so
angry WBC's yeah the WBC's of Raymond
Everett and it's also lazy because
there's a there are a lot of things to
be angry about but then that's so gay
marriage he's never done anything
overtly racist to anybody that you can
see so like who you fighting you kill
your enemies you stop bloodlust what's
the problem here
but it's like they're trying to start
this fraternity and it's if you do
anything that they that they deem you
know that you can be thrown out there
like you know now you're out you're
right but it's like a club that doesn't
really even matter though anyway but
when the Sun in their club does it okay
they they they in their head they find
out way to make it oh no
he's actually making fun of that you
know I remember a guy said that because
you know Sarah Silverman said some
pretty racy words and absolutely
louis c.k used to say all the time
mostly they all love their but she took
a little bit of you to not yeah for the
conan to come the conan game took it
from asians I'm talking about the WBC's
you just don't see it because it's like
go out there I'm not on those feet man
but I do think I do think rage is its
selective and it's also stylized that it
like literally like a shirt goes in and
out of style what they're mad about goes
in and out of style
because like you know in 2002 I think
when Polanski won an Academy Award they
gave him a standing ovation right he's
exile exiled in France and so whatever
he did in the 70s they thought okay
let's let's let it go he's a great
director Cosby gets his problem and now
they're kicking him both out of the
Academy look at Kobe Bryant you gave him
a standing ovation yeah how do you have
a meet to Oscar and give Kobe something
which is crazy right that's that it's
like what while he so it's what he's
doing is so great by the way a lot of
what he's doing isn't that great but
yeah I do like when he breaks down with
the game but yeah that's interesting but
it's not like it's not like I don't know
it's not but it is I love basketball
[ __ ] yeah I guess the cartoons about
like Isiah Thomas okay is something
chamber that he put out oh they like the
rage chambers a weird name JB the weird
dude the news chambers are you alright
jerks often amused chamber he really
does that's what they called it little
not next to the big nut they call it the
muse tuner and and so this rage is
becoming addictive to where they need
it's like it needs to be fed so what
what did someone do today that we can be
angry about and you're not even
understanding each single thing that
you're angry about you just sort of like
get angry next thing get angry it's just
like you can be allergic to addicted
excuse me to adrenalin so it's like
we're addicted to the adrenaline and but
not addicted to like really knowing
what's happening like with this guy I
mean he's either a joke or you disagree
with him but he shouldn't lose his job
back in the day you had to like leave
your house and join a mob you'd be get a
[ __ ]
need to get a pitchfork you can sharpen
it up now you just get at a keyboard you
eat your Funyuns and it's very easy now
and then he went back to a tweet of his
from 2008 who does that by the wave you
ever gone through a time where it takes
a long time to even go through like two
days if someone's talking on tree-sweets
okay really I don't know I've done it
once for myself but will you just check
in if you had anything in the closet you
know your Twitter plus you get murder so
you get a report of all the tweets
you've ever done from who like a teacher
they're like Duany like you mr. gamma
here is an app but I was trying to I was
submitting to a gift card company some
gift card jokes so I was like well let
me just thought well my my old tweets we
get a sample they didn't buy any of the
jokes so but I did it for myself once I
can't imagine doing it for someone else
and I had an objective I was trying to
like extract jokes that I could use
again who was it they found the UH
what's Josh Allen the quarterback had
tweets from like high school yeah yeah
can we just can we say something if I
purchase a rap song and I put the lyrics
can we agree I'm not calling anybody the
n-word I mean he actually use the n-word
right here and it's like no things did
they they go anywhere they even said oh
he was quoting uh it was and it was a
quote he quoted the lyrics from a rap
song that's the end of it we all move on
right right right
we can't all love NWA not talk about
what the name is right yeah I mean I
don't tell me to buy their albums and
then tell me I can't say I like the band
get the [ __ ] out of here you ever have
you a significant other
be angry about something and then drop
an N bomb on you happened to me almost
every day but then within the thing they
were angry about get some perspective
and it wasn't that thing like like maybe
they thought you were watching looking
at that girl turns out you weren't
looking at the girl you're looking at
the statue you were looking at a guy
you were looking at a girl right let's
say but let's say you weren't but then
it takes so it takes them a while to get
for the anger to go away even though
what the well right like what you mad
about didn't exist right so I don't I
guess you just it takes a while for that
anger like you can't just I cut it off
I'm like oh I was wrong
boom that's it but most people they
still mad at you this is weird it's a
weird space they know they don't have a
right to be but they're still mad people
would rather be right than do right so
then you get more explanation right
right right now there's a major
conundrum I think it's in Canada you
guys hear about this there was a a
transgender man to woman went into a
went into a waxing place I got it okay
and they were like I just need my legs
waxed but when they got into the actual
waxing place they wanted the Brazilian
in the wax there was a Muslim woman and
she said I don't touch men outside of
like my husband I'm religiously
prohibited so now people are like whoa
whose side do we take both are like
waxing they're they'll work to jump you
had a guy bleed cherries [ __ ]
yeah oh so what do you take
transgendered it's like they're both oh
we think both of them are pure innocent
beautiful creatures now that's the
conundrum who wins this battle yes that
woman at CBS version when they were
talking about you know me to happen and
then you know actually it took down some
people then it started more like well
hold on some of these people seem like
they might be like being strung up or
something that's not really that bad and
maybe like a false accusation or just
something it's not quite as simple and
she goes and so that was like it are
people worried about like some innocent
people getting punished she goes I'm
hearing this all the time innocent
people getting punished you know what I
don't give a [ __ ] if a few innocent man
get punished oh yeah do she side down
and yeah and then people tweeted out it
goes so you don't care if black men get
punished for something they didn't do he
goes wait what no how about your own son
on you it was about rape she was
bringing
that of people being falsely accused of
rape and she said she didn't care and it
became like a protected group she's like
no that's not cool they're going to eat
themselves alive right well I think you
can outrage the outrageous because it's
laziness if you get mad about a
particular thing and you know the
details of that thing and you you keep
your anger to that thing then you're in
a good place but it's it that takes so
much work because you have to read like
like when I talk about certain things
things that happened I've read like like
a police case you think so it's not easy
you have to be a really fast reader to
like read the transcript read the police
call read like and now you know what
happened and you have a more informed
opinion but that took twenty thirty
maybe an hour hour of your life to do
that yeah I'm a dedicated yeah they come
at you with the headline of an article
like Trevor Noah's racist tweets now
already you're at the place of like let
me see these erasers or not instead of
just let me see these are funny or not
right no you're already thinking the way
they want you to think so then it's
either I hate you or I don't care either
way and here's what Wells dr. we've all
said the same thing for years now it's
just a question of like listen guys
we're gonna catch a cold here there
we're gonna get some people angry at us
and it's just like whatever I'll take my
lumps let's move on yep it's the Hammad
you can't convince them this thousands
about what is but it's no longer I don't
think you're funny I'm not gonna laugh
at the show or I'm not gonna go to the
next one it's I need to organize a
boycott for future shows and other
venues it's like it's no longer like I
don't know like if you don't like a
movie don't go see the sequel it's not
like everyone needs to boycott the
sequel because I I don't like that movie
it's like you just that you liked it
didn't abstain we also allow the meek to
pick the rules that's my problem like
what we allow political correctness and
comedy do is basically letting the last
kid in kickball who gets picked and
kickball to pick the rules of the
playground and it's like no dude that's
not how it works
you didn't like that joke move the [ __ ]
on
it's Louie it's who cares and also it
becomes like you said like okay even if
someone's wrong does that mean their
livelihood
be permanently limited permanently for
the rest of their lives
like for one thing they did they could
never make money again that's that's
crazy
what's weird though is that comics are
being judged like we're [ __ ] you know
like politician Trump said grab that our
presidents and grab them by the [ __ ]
he's not losing his job but it's like
this [ __ ] guy with a cooking show his
jobs not rewarded so that's a thing but
now if he presented he he put somebody
in charge of what I don't know the
[ __ ] you know whatever position he
could appoint somebody those people get
it taken away
of an elected official doesn't count
that's why that roaring water I almost
got elected well it's also it's also
that people see comedy as patty-cakes
they don't realize that there's
sometimes we're trying to shed light on
some stuff it's the most time it's dick
jokes you know and that's fine but it's
like there's also we want to talk about
something and just because you think you
you're you want to hear about dad
farting I am we're trying to talk about
something else it's not the end of work
it's if we do a joke about some it's
we're not ridiculing it we're trying to
give our take on what is going on like
Mark Norman got in trouble at the state
and funnybone because he did a bit about
like school shooter trouble real trouble
was it just a bunch of tweets or was it
yeah
that's the people were calling for him
to be banned from that club was he go so
he wasn't so there really is no trouble
all these comments do the same [ __ ] with
like I got in trouble you didn't get in
trouble you got some people angry you
because you told a [ __ ] out there
joke and by the way what 5,000 people
liked his tweet about the straight white
man so a few people hated it they got
mad if you're mad just laugh at those
people you didn't get in trouble
you got you got threatened with trouble
okay alright well also if you if you ban
this guy then you you are like whatever
it's a this is not a joke and say he
feels like straight white men are being
marginalized in some way or fashion then
you do this do you reinforce it you make
him now even his stance even more
accurate see I told you they're
marginalizing us as opposed to talking
to him is saying well
here's why I think you're not being
marginalized or why I think your
statement was a bit of an overstatement
but you you banned them from everything
you make him a martyr in his own mind
and in the mind of people around them
and it's like but now you just you just
created a bigger wedge you haven't yeah
it's like people come after whoever it
is right or left you know they come
after somebody it's like okay what you
want I think what you guys want is for
them not to do that anymore but your
tactics never achieve that goal right
the only really piqued people ignore you
or double down so like I get if you feel
strongly about something but the way
you're going about it is definitely
wrong be are you rallying people behind
me let me tell you why this is wrong it
caught in a calm way it's just
anger it's like whoever's gonna respond
to that you make oh my god okay you make
the other side ah you make the others
are you're making the baby cry your
ain't you're doing err is making the
baby um guys you know tomorrow there'll
be another comic who is getting yelled
at and and that's the thing he then
he'll be he'll he'll be off it all he
needs is like a Cosby news thing to come
up or Megan Markel to get her period
right uh
to have the news cycle go to that
watching that wedding was just I mean
like I was staying with my mom I've met
Megan Markel out of the city
as I was I was a grocery delivery driver
back in the day and she was a customer
oh very freckly she puts a lot of makeup
over those freckles and black freckles I
think that's hot she was an attractive
lady I didn't know she would go on to be
royalty she shouldn't hide the freckles
I've always said like maybe Harry said
no freckles right one wit one freckle
family one freckle person family being a
hot chick I like a super hot chick is
the easiest way to move up social skills
oh my god I was just talking about this
way that's absolutely are you jerking
off Ari this is the part of the show
where it goes to sleep
oh you're sleeping well that's a huge
dick oh wow it's high up there that is
royalty right there that looks like
somebody on [ __ ]
farmers only what's her title now
Duchess Duchess Duchess yeah yeah and
she's just hugely rich and they just and
they literally said she's okay you can
marry someone who's black since you're
the sixth in line to get the get the
throw it feels like two or three way
they'd be like nah yeah you happen to
have some oh you're six yeah get your
freak on remember when Harry dressed up
as a Nazi just having some good times
ladies like now I like black people it's
oh wait are you Jewish - let's get to it
one wait well I get a hot girl can like
literally become a princess you can
especially with uh you know social media
you can like just go to a show and like
a hot chick and meet anyone but they're
now dudes who getting arrested they're
like wow this guy is a [ __ ] great
mugshot yeah let's give them a deal with
these he's now these guys are models and
it's I don't know what crimes they're
committing but they're criminal that's
outrageous
yeah I mean well here's the thing about
like Instagram models they have no class
- they're gay you know they buy all
those followers and we're like why is
this chick have a million [ __ ] file
because she buys them all and we won't
do that
when you look at the likes though that's
the real key somebody was like who they
said Danny V you know it's like is that
another Food Network personality guys ah
we're in the stretch of all the great
sports yeah we are you guys talk to
sports yet we are we talked a lot of it
and we're gonna talk about more cuz
we're gonna talk about bet des I bet the
aside for all your bet needs that's
right go to bet decide calm use the
promo code punch 25 and you'll get 25
punch 25 are you putting it in its punch
25 I bet the aside calm can you bet on
Ellis mania dude you want them to I'll
talk to them they'll make bets why not
we'll make it to it the Ferrari bets up
and then they'll take it off the board
cuz he runs all the time and the oh okay
so your dude you should come on tinfoil
hat and talk about that conspiracy well
you're
saying is that I called them up and we
got together we go help we make re look
bad could have been it could have been a
email no no if you try to dump me what
about me looking back it was about you
I'm ducking you won't bite me every time
I said yes on a date figure out a way
out okay fine
yes on a date in September it off and
then it all sounds like oh how about end
of August I want to fight you so back as
you make the baby cry I want to fight
you so [ __ ] dude is this we're like it
what is this like we're sitcom goes to
[ __ ] when they bring a baby on the show
is that we're always that are we about
to just a shark can you what the baby
hey bet this I bet on everything and be
a playoff Major League Baseball your
Yankees are doing well what's your
football gets and Giants but no cats and
then ah you can do pro run we can do all
UFC hey oh that's the pro wrestling you
can bet on that right no you can't no I
think you can I think if you have you're
a writer you're like I'm putting I know
the results I don't think I did you can
maybe you can bet on like how it happens
you can't bet on them but do you know if
you're a writer you know how it happens
that's true those guys why would they
let you bet on I don't know I think you
can was it in the internet fans are
gonna say just okay if they're realistic
oh my god are you kidding
you can bet so if you're a writer you're
like I'm putting a million dollars and
then Vince McMahon's like I by the way I
lied if you're a [ __ ] athlete you can
bet a million dollars another team just
won't be an athlete
well you know the Floyd Mayweather try
to bet on himself on the round they're
like no well you can't bet I saw the
little throat he'll like dock finish
somebody on purpose but I saw that
documentary over the top with Sylvester
Stallone and he bet it on himself and he
won that awesome truck that's true
and that was a real event was that 3430
yeah ESPN 30 for 30
what are the capsules [ __ ] for
straight neither I think they I think
they're in it is aren't the Vegas
new Vegas huh - so what's the Vegas have
you seen the Cavalier capital oh I think
they can yeah it's like whoa cocky took
the capitalism song you can swim hockey
there's some black hockey players a lot
of like I could place I know by Jones
all right
Vegas is wet waiting no there is it yeah
yeah that's amazing what's their name
the casinos there no they're the golden
Knight go then the golden Fieri's by the
way Guy Fieri is I went to the same
College as UNLV yeah I actually watch
the show it wasn't that bad Triple D
yeah it is that bad maybe laughter one
way eats all types of young when he just
says everything's great and it's not
everything's flavortown yeah oh this is
like a pot this is like the Sharks
because like card shark talk the shark
those would be all great names for a
Vegas team do you remember back in the
day when the shark with Mt I'm a big
bellied guy I like a cow me tell me I
call it give me the best yoga teacher
stretch that cometo me do you remember
when the San Jose Sharks came into the
league was it just me or was every Asian
person wearing the Hat no my favorite
thing yeah for sure and my favorite
thing is all the Lake Asian Laker fans
are now all Golden State warrior fans
like if you know they're like no I'm
from California
Gretchen's the whole state it goes up
they're actually video them up from the
bay you know well I know because his lie
yeah they're the worst
they all love Jeremy Lin who was good
for what 3 minutes oh man Jeremy Lin
almost got me back into liking the
Knicks like I was really all my fell
into that trap was down with that one
Saturday man I really was huh I was
great I was little I was Lin saying in
the membrane that I guess that's a catch
but it didn't do it maybe that's the
next one if he does it with his man but
he's a big Jesus lover he was good dude
I wouldn't watch him in a summer league
he lit John Wall up
is that right he lit John Wall up
you're talking like you literally lit
him on fire yeah Oh with a magnifying
glass
yeah yes I mean like he's good he you
know pom was they realize he couldn't go
left yeah once they realize what you
can't do
like his height they got a little they
got ten days of film on him I know all
right high school team went won the
state champion he's the only player on
that team did not get a scholarship to
go play because they're like Asians
can't ball that's so crazy what they
ought was it like a was it
a predominantly Asian school or was a
was he the only Asian guy on the team I
think it was a regular team like you
know I'm gonna go on to play in the NBA
I'm gonna be a starter in the NBA yeah
can't be more wrong about this he's
gonna have Harvard right and he's gonna
have a Dragonball Z haircut like he
loves the Dragon Ball Z that haircut
like Asians porcupine that was it
creates a divide in the locker room cuz
he never eats with a fork oh my god
that's so funny
look at the many hairdos oh look at the
dreadlocks
that's a Whoopi Goldberg right there
honest guys he's got the Bruce Lee circa
nineteen they can do anything he got in
trouble
some teammate sauce scolded him about
the cornrows and the dreadlocks they
call the cultural appropriation dude
that's the yeah they'd walk be really
good that's what they can he said like
oh I'm gonna unaware of this stuff look
I just wanted to have the haircut like
shut the [ __ ] off so when it's cultural
bridge doesn't mohawk is no that's weird
is like well that's because if you're a
minority you know but he's also minority
so it's like that's true are they a
majority yet yes political correctness
to the only crimes or statistics that
matter are what happens within these
borders like there hasn't been
millenniums of [ __ ] people do an evil
ass [ __ ] it just cracks just like it's
like dude I get attacked by Asians all
the time they'd love to go crazy I
physically no they don't attack me face
about the tinfoil hat stuff no just
about like um I did Tiffany had a show
at USC and I uh
this woman said that one of my jokes
about how like I was driving home at
night I saw this woman jogging I she
said ah Santa's jokes about women
jogging night he likes to rape them
that's not the joke you're protecting
that's just been real there's a joke
behind the truth though the best ring
they have that [ __ ] smell you go to
the marathon and you're just salivating
yeah so they Sam was already a rapist
he's just doing a general wish type of
person he wants to rape oh yeah yeah
yeah Jeremy Lin I'm looking at the
screen has more [ __ ] hairdos and I've
ever seen a one person think two is like
I get black face being offensive for
sure but if you can do whatever you can
do it your hair do it the cultural
appropriation is the dumbest most
made-up [ __ ] I've ever seen in my
life it's weird cuz like Ari and I are
Jews but bagels are great we want
everyone to enjoy them like you don't
want to pull your thing to you're like
this is my toy no one touches I think I
think there's a fair I think I think
what comes from there's a fear of like
people accepting some of your aesthetics
but not accepting you right so you want
to try to put but you can't police that
like like so people like you want you
want people to get braids and then maybe
know a little bit about black people but
you can't police that like this is
America you can get your marrieds and
not know anything those braids on a
white girl yeah the white girl I do the
research and I don't know that the white
girl oh cool we should make tests just
can't police everything you know just
wear your hair the way you want to wear
it this is a melting pot and we all get
to do whatever everyone's yeah you stem
from something so it's like I mean I
dreadlock my pubes but only certain
people see it that sounds like a great
that's the new hip-hop thing right again
her elbow if he you know if someone has
those braids like bagels we really do
like typically a like you know a super
right wing person is not gonna have
braids right no typically so if a guy
has dread Jeremy Lin and then if you
give him you give him [ __ ] for it you're
pushing him away especially a guy who's
around
a lot of black guys a lot of black
culture so it's like I don't think he's
not mocking anybody just wanted to have
the [ __ ] haircut man let the guy like
if you appropriate someone's culture
they don't lose their culture yeah they
want that's a great point
what's into it just like when there's
some new musician and you want to be the
only person who knows about them and
then when they become huge you're kind
of like cool yeah like if all it is
that's a great point I can when I go to
eat dim sum
they give me dim sum now there was a
limited supply of them some they may
hold out on I don't know Asian guys they
may serve them first we have to is only
a certain amount of you know what I mean
yeah we all go just start a rap you know
why is it on the radio we just all start
taking our [ __ ] back I like do we want
to do that the beauty I like them some
I'm not gonna stop that just got it's
hot it just causes more separation than
anything I think it's all fake what
Peavey's are done by people that cause
like that woman calling the cops
on the guy barbecuing like part of me
thinks that's fake ass [ __ ] and it's
done on purpose get everybody angry at
each other it's an area for barbecuing
who's gonna call duties but it's like it
doesn't make any [ __ ] sense the
baby's crying
she might be vegetarian we're not sure
yet well I get that you don't want to be
mocked so like if it's done in mockery I
think that's one thing but even if
they're mocking you it's like again
blackface is mocking blackface is
mocking right wearing it Okamoto to a
prom is not mock not mocking and so but
even if you thought it was mocking it's
like well unless you think the mocking
leads exactly there's a direct line from
mocking to limiting what you can do to
like some sort of discrimination even
that like okay you shouldn't do that but
I'm not gonna lose sleep over it because
I'm living my life over here now if
somehow that leads to me not getting a
job if you can make that argument okay
fine yeah it's like when you see who's
that girl that ran the NC NC and then
double AC P yeah Rachel Rachel yeah
she wasn't hooking she was like Hamas
was really loving it she was in it yeah
right but that would be cultural
appropriation if anything right but then
it was like lying about her kids were
black - she did have black kids that
chick is black right right why can't you
be fluid like that like the rule there's
just dumb rules on everything you know
it's just like that's why the left so
screwed is because they make a rule and
then instantly they realize ah we're
hypocrites if we follow through
especially if you go back far enough
like okay she's not technically black
but we were all from Africa so she could
also play that card if she wanted to you
know like all y'all from Africa I'm from
African booty scratcher you know if you
spend that much money on tanning and
perming be black enjoy well also she
sorry for yelling is my favorite thing
ever because who is Sam Tripoli she's
not yelling
well there's kid hearing and dropping
f-bombs why is this woman why this lady
crying why is this lady crying about a
barbecue later she's like yeah I didn't
hear by the way I saw the funniest they
throw her out is that why she's upset
yeah well no she called the cops ago the
cops here
I saw the funniest sketch about this
it's a woman going around like
complaining about black people and then
like she gets to its you know when these
Instagram videos and she gets to a
light-skinned black dude and she's like
and then he says to his friend he's like
yo did you get that burger was the
problem loud for her liking like well
issue I didn't see the whole video but I
think she said video you had the wrong
they had the wrong kind of grill her
hand is jammed into that bony parts
look at that left hand is really jammed
in there and then they they found out
where she worked it should I get her
fired but she was crying and she might
be touching herself she is correct
this conflict give me your number well
the cops showed up and they were like
wait what shut up
like the cops like you know we have a
lot of bad PR now cop knows what it's
like to be a comic because there's
always that lady in the crowd yeah hi
can I talk to you these jokes are like
there were four jokes that I took except
one was just unfunny but every I took
exception to my friends kid is a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I hate that joke
don't go to the best is Ryan Holtzman
and handling that cuz I've seen people
yell at him like what he does cancer
jokes and this woman stood up and she
was walking out and she's like I had
cancer you [ __ ] anything you
should've died [ __ ] look you've got
apologizing I'm going all there to move
in the chips what's great is that the
phone is plugged into something so like
but it's to her ear so if she she's like
a charger in a pocket yeah that's what's
going on her racist phone is dying
she carries carries an extension cord to
her home it's like a cell phone it's
like a landline in pink can with a
string right there who or is behind her
those are the barbecue barbecue in a
park that's a code is that guys offering
her cigar that's an F barbecue on the
range it's a different phone some people
are just a small barbecue like she just
needed attention that Deschanel said she
is now I guarantee you taken so much
more abuse than any punishment should be
right right but now you know I mean it's
like what an oculist all bothersome is
barbecue and now she is being lambasted
to ever she can't go out in public with
nothing made fun of it's like I'm like
if it's real and I don't think it's real
I think it's staged to make people want
to fight with each other but if it's
real you know it may be station you need
it it's [ __ ] her man hey you're [ __ ]
barbecuing there it's like it's so
stupid it makes everybody look bad why
did it like what what bothered her that
they were using a wrong grill and easily
yeah first she said you can't barbecue I
think and then they said what we can
then she said well not with that kind of
grill what are we she who the [ __ ] do
something just keep walking on her you
know
she has no problems in her life she does
now but at this moment she was just
bored movie go Jews you have to leave
that conversation with my husband or I
am a forest ranger
if that's not the first thing you say
this chick hasn't gotten quality dick in
a long time she's [ __ ] angry get
[ __ ] angry you know what is a babe I
don't know how she's not getting dick
down imagine if we had an alternative
unified I don't think you as a fat white
chick I don't think you want to pick off
black guys right you shouldn't be pissed
off but the thing is what if we if we
could rewind rewind time in this moment
and one of these black guys just sort of
just start macking her yeah this video
doesn't even happen she comes over this
could be the beginning of a porno race
although I chick gets a black dick down
are those sausage is oh they're so juicy
I bet you they will do a pawn based on
this video why not yeah that's the new
it's a new porno YouTube parodies Dwayne
Perkins you survived your first punch
drunk
thank you want you uh tell them we're
going to all yourself no walk I'll see
you tonight I'm at the Laugh Factory
Hollywood right up the street from there
Bobby Bobby tell good jokes but the
Thursday night I mean Thursday 24th on
in Malibu Malibu wines so come check out
that show and 29th and 30th of June I'll
be in Shanghai at the calm cool comedy
club nice nice we got La listeners in
North Korea if you ever get booked there
I'm trying to good news yes have you
ever been to China yes yeah I've been
I've been before I've been all over yeah
my favorite thing kung fu comedy club in
Shanghai and I'm also doing gigs on
Malaysia Oh end of June and in the
beginning of July I'll be in Malaysia
and Singapore I don't know those exact I
love when they're like oh is the USO
I'm going to China right there's no
military US military there yeah exactly
what are you [ __ ] talking about not
yet ari real quick can you give your
dates because you didn't get a chance
yeah DC washington DC december 1st 2nd
or 3rd do your parents go come up with
that December December yeah you
okay I got ya I got you how your parents
gonna go yeah they're going on Sunday
their knowledge immaterial are you from
DC oh all right well great way then this
Ben punch-drunk we love you guys we'll
see you next time
cement our weekend in my house once in
my crazy neighbor came I did his podcast